[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans point de vue
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
réagissent et faites nous part de vos
commentaires
via twitter hashtag figaro live [ __ ]
de vue nous allons bien sûr parlé du
sommet sur le climat qui se tient
aujourd'hui à paris un nouvel élan
sera-t-il vraiment donnée à la lutte
contre le réchauffement ou emmanuel
macron en fait-il un peu trop pour
cultiver son image en titre up c'est ce
qu'on va voir ensemble
la communication n'est pas absente non
plus du sang moi lâché hier par aviez
bertrand à destination de laurent
wauquiez
ce départ finalement en espagne tempête
dans un verre d'eau
chacun a sans doute son point de vue là
dessus quant aux bons chiffres de sur
l'emploi publié ce matin
peut-on s'en réjouir la france crée des
emplois de salariés mais cela at il un
véritable impact sur le chômage n'est
peut-être pas évident enfin nous feront
un détour par béziers beziers qui vit à
l'heure du western et des trains à
vapeur c'est en tout cas la défense de
son maire robert ménard pour justifier
une campagne d'affichage très contesté
robert ménard toujours doué pour faire
parler de lui merci à vous quatre d'être
ici pour en débattre
bonjour jean marc four bonjour vous êtes
directeur des rédactions de france inter
est fidèle à point de vue votre dernier
livre et de la mécanique médiatique est
paru chez le mieux c'était en 2016 un
bon jour charles beigbeder vous êtes un
homme d'affaires vous faites aussi de la
politique avec robert ménard dont on
vient de parler vous avez participé à un
colloque intitulé hausse la droite
visant à l'union des droites et vous
avez écrit charnellement de france paru
chez pierre guillaume d'euros en 2016
bonjour erwan le nord vous êtes
consultant stratégie vous enseigne à
sciences po et vous êtes l'auteur de la
france des opportunités toutes les
bonnes nouvelles qu'on ne vous dit pas
séparés aux belles lettres
cette année alors cet emploi salarié en
hausse et il a arrangé au chapitre des
bonnes nouvelles marc landré vous allez
nous le dira
vous êtes très d'acteurs en chef au
service économie du figaro et vous êtes
aussi fidèle au poste merci tout est là
pour très sage toujours très sage c'est
sûr on va le vérifier
alors encore un sommet pour la planète
serait on tenté de dire
bill gates
arnold schwarzenegger michael bloomberg
les américains sont presque tous à paris
évidemment il manque donald trump autour
d' emmanuel macron c'est une quarantaine
de chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui
sont réunis ainsi que des centaines
d'entreprises de fonds souverains et de
représentants de la finance alors le
grand capital peut-il venir au secours
de la planète c'est ce qu'on va voir
dans un instant après avoir écouté un
extrait du discours d' emmanuel macron
discours qu'il vient de prononcer devant
ses invités à boulogne billancourt
prétaille quand je dis qu'on est en
train de perdre la bataille aujourd'hui
je veux que vous preniez conscience que
derrière moi il ya des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement dans 50 60 ou 100 ans
il y en a 5 10 15 qui ne seront plus là
tout simplement ça veut dire ça ce qu'on
est en train de faire on peut pas on
pourra pas dire qu'on ne sait pas c'est
ce qu'on est en train de décider à ne
pas changer on décide juste qu'il y en a
plusieurs
autour de cette table qui vont
disparaître leur population avec eux ce
que nous entamons aujourd'hui c'est le
temps de l'action
parce que l'urgence est devenue
permanente
on voit un discours bref pour une fois
sans fioritures assez direct jean marc
four est ce que manuel macro emmanuel ma
couette en train de prendre le
leadership de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique
en tout cas ils le souhaitent ils
essaient de le faire en tout cas c'est à
dire que c'est un bel affichage on veut
pas contesté qu'il ya un bel affichage
que la devanture est assez séduisante
effectivement vous avez donné un peu le
plateau tout à l'heure la vraie question
c'est est-ce que derrière l'affichage il
se passe vraiment quelque chose en
cuisine
est-ce que de fait parce que emmanuel
macron un problème en raison de dire qui
est dès 23h55 et qu'il faut agir vite
est-ce que de fait on va réussir à agir
vite et quelle part vont prendre
particulièrement les partenaires privés
et les entreprises les banques les
assurances etc
dans ce dispositif puisque c'est en
grande partie à l'enjeu 2
de ce sommet d'aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement le financement le nerf de
la guerre
charles beigbeder juste sur la forme
déjà effectivement il fait de l'anti
trump est ce qui peut s'afficher comme
le monsieur climat de la planète
c'est bien c'est bien je crois qu'on a
besoin de ces sommets pour mobiliser
tous les terriens toute la planète parce
que c'est un problème quand même on
aimait 40 milliards de tonnes de co2 par
an et la planète peut en absorber que 10
milliards dont caf à force il va y avoir
un problème
alors est ce que oui alors sans doute ça
accélère le réchauffement
rappelons quand même que le
réchauffement n'est pas dû seulement aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
peut-être aussi le cycle de l'étoile
donc soyons prudents quand même quand on
dit c'est uniquement à cause des gaz à
effet de serre que la planète se
réchauffe c'est un peu dangereux
georges est il qu'il faut lutter contre
cela le problème que de ses sommets
c'est que ça devient très très
bureaucratique et techniques et que les
gens n'y comprennent plus rien les
particuliers et même les entreprises
parce que est donc là je pense qu'il
faudrait un moment qu'on imagine des
solutions plus simples qui
responsabilise et responsabilise chaque
terrien et qu'on dise bas puisque ces 10
milliards de tonnes pas pour pour la
plaine de parents qu'on ait cette
meilleure mais c'est une tonne et demie
par personne donc et que l'on aide les
gens à calculer leurs émissions
erwan le nom vous êtes d'accord des gens
ne comprennent rien oui je passais les
gens n'y comprennent plus rien que je
suis pas convaincu que ça intéresse a
été tant que ça les opinions publiques
ce sommet pour autant ça n'enlève rien
au fait que c'est un événement politique
important qu emmanuel macron a su
prendre le lit de niveau international
alors toutefois j'ai regardé la presse
internationale avant de venir la
pression de glaxo n'y a pas une ligne
sur le sur le sommet donc je sais pas
c'est que ça les intéresse pas aussi
parce qu'en france on fait plus que dans
le dos les autres pays parce que ça se
passe chez nous en tout cas emmanuel
macron appris après une position qui est
politiquement très forte
on l'a entendu les d'expression qui sont
très fortes je ne sais s'il a donné
aujourd'hui une interview au monde cet
après midi une très longue interview il
y avait plein de propos très intéressant
effectivement on voit pas encore comment
ça se traduit il ya de grandes ambitions
internationales
on voit pas exactement comment s'il est
réaliste de penser qu'il va pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre des sanctions au niveau
international qui va emporter tout le
monde ça ça reste un peu fou par contre
j'en finis par la très bonne initiative
à mon sens c'est qu'il dit maintenant
c'est plus les zetas et au secteur privé
d'agir et je suis convaincu que c'est
par le privé qu'on arrivera à changer
les choses alors ça me fait une
tradition pour marc landré tout trouver
ce que vous serez vite se saisir oui
enfin il n'a pas attendu et emmanuel
macron la coop 21-22-23 que sais-je et
44 même pour reprenez edf edf qui a
décidé qu annoncé hier un grand plan de
développement sur dans les énergies
solaire je veux dire s'il n'a pas
attendu la coop 22 23 pour le faire on
prend angie qui depuis deux ans a décidé
de se suffire de se débarrasser de 80%
de son core business traditionnel qui
était trop carbonées pour aller vers des
énergies du futur pour le faire
moi ce que je trouve pour rebondir sur
sur l'interrogation est ce qu'on n'y
comprend quelque chose est-ce que ça
intéresse les gens
parce que c'est quand même ça la base de
la base c'est des gens qui polluent
entre guillemets et que ça doit
intéresser
on a eu la cote 21 il ya deux ans la
coop 22 l'année dernière la coop 23
cette année à francfort
maintenant dans le mythe climat tso met
à paris je veux dire franchement les
gens sous vêtements paumé et je
rajouterais une chose entre la guerre la
grève aujourd'hui du rer a et b mais les
embêter les embouteillages contre paris
franchement les gens là ils auront
jusque là dès qu'ils sont sur le climat
qui ne saute ceux qui n'ont pas de lien
avec leur quotidien
surtout en matière de transports
fonctionnent si je peux ajouter quelque
chose sur sur cette esthétique et rdf
rapidement c'est bien de passer de 7000
mégawatts à 30 mille mégawatts de
solaire d'ici d'ici 20 ans mais je ne
suis pas sûr que la solution soit
uniquement dans les grandes centrales
photovoltaïques au sol qui va accélérer
la bétonisation de nos terroirs
moi je pense qu'il faut un peu de ça et
beaucoup de
de transformation de nos toitures des
toitures de nos bâtiments de nos
pavillons de nos maisons à l'aide de
panneaux photovoltaïques on y va dans
des solutions qui favorisent l'auto
consommation énergétique notamment
alors avant d'aborder le très concret un
petit retour sur emmanuel macron qui
effectivement a donné une interview à
cbs des premiers réseaux américains
toujours pour se poser en contre en
adversaire de trump sur cette question
l'écoutent et noé tu protèges aux
personnes présentes
yes i'm not ready to negotiate putnam
ready to a quand même il fait 10 ans
qu'on faisait la moue charles beigbeder
c'est du wishful thinking de penser que
trump a changé après une interview de
maniema creux emmanuel macron exagère un
petit peu le traité n'avait pas été
ratifié par le congrès américain donc on
peut pas dire que les états unis avaient
souvent les deux traités parce qu'un
petit peu incorrect un petit peu
impertinent je trouve pas aux américains
puis en plus un pont à l'hôpital qui se
fout de la gueule la charité si vous me
permettez tout malgré tout respecter
pour prise en mains publiques
il a fait exactement la même chose sur
la scène européenne avec les travers des
tâches et il y avait un accord qui avait
été bouclée qu'ils étaient prêts à être
transposée dans chacun des états il est
arrivé après son élection disant moi je
ne suis pas reliés par ce qu'a fait mon
prédécesseur ou pas ce qui a été décidé
par le haut niveau du conseil européen
par l'ensemble des autres et a donc je
m'en lave les mains et je demande à ce
qu'on renégocie ce traité et finalement
on va avoir quelque chose d'un petit peu
différent mais qui va qui reporte n'ont
pas aujourd'hui mais à 2022 des
décisions qu aurait pu être faite de dès
maintenant
il ya quelque chose un petit peu
troublant c'est que d'un côté vous avez
cet affichage très fort effectivement
alors maintenant là qu'on profite du
fait que son french president ruff a
déserté que theresa may
et la merguez de côté en ce moment donc
d'accord il ya un très beau leadership
d'affichage etc
mais sur le fond peut pas dire que la
france montre particulièrement l'exemple
sur le sujet si on prend par exemple le
sujet des énergies renouvelables moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'on est plutôt
en retard par rapport à nos partenaires
européens on va pas abreuvés les gens
qui nous regardent nous écoutent deux
chiffres en enfin les chiffres sont très
spectaculaires et si par exemple ne
prenons pas le photovoltaïque
effectivement terriens prenons l'éolien
offshore alors là c'est juste là bas
c'est simple éolien offshore à bail et
c'est sam
alors combien en france 2 000 mesures
qu'on gèle en effet je parle et ça parce
que j'ai souvenir d'avoir couvert en
grande bretagne le lancement des grandes
fermes offshore au large du pays de
galles c'était il ya quasiment dix ans
il ya quasiment dix ans nous on en est à
zéro et l'éolien représente moins de 2
de la production et cinq en france de la
course
la géographie n'est pas tout à fait la
même on en a on a plus de profondeur
il ya deux les eaux où c'est possible
sur des zones où on a beaucoup de mais
on accroche
je me disais qu écolo entre les alizés
corman d'arroser et
mix britannique qui doit être de l'ordre
de 35% de l'éolien et de lolya offshore
il ya quand même de la marge
c'est clair on a des écolos foule
chénier maintenant mais personne n'a
vraiment non plus envie d'avoir un champ
d'éoliennes chez soi sont la réforme
cinq ans mais c'est intéressant
oui c'est intéressant jir personne n'y a
que d'habiter côté sauf ceux qui sont
sur plateforme pétrolière la limite on
leur dit oui moi je trouve cette idée
puisque organiseront pourrait quand même
fait ce choix il on sait plus 18 ou 20 %
de leur mix de leur production d'exciter
qui et qui dieu que des lésions
vaginales aussi du nucléaire que et
qu'il faut arrêter de dire le nucléaire
c'est le mal c'est clair on a cet atout
incroyable sauf qu'elle doit payer dont
la part de production était cité pour
contrefaçon il faut quoi pourrait-elle
vous fêtez la loi c'est la loi mais on
sait le faire on a cette chance et ça
peut profiter à nos grands industriels
électro-intensifs énormément cher le
coût et le faible coût l'électricité du
a dû au nucléaire le faible coût les que
c'était en france on la paye avoue enfin
parce que ça ça va oui mais je sais ce
faible coût du à la part du nucléaire
nous a empêché une certaine manière de
regarder en face au rejet du
renouvelable
un peu plus tôt et fait je vous donne
les premières réponses à notre question
qui était donc c'est ce sommet est ce
que c'est un simple affichage est à 70%
de nos internautes répondent que oui
c'est de l'affichage plus que de
l'action on va écouter bruno le maire
bruno le maire -ministre de l'économie
il était ce matin l'invité de france
inter et il parle de la finance lui de
cette économie verte
ce qui veut dire au 1er janvier 4 à 5
centimes d'euros de plus par litre de
diesel pour les particuliers il faudrait
qu'on atteigne environ 30 euros la tonne
c'est un prix indicatif que je donne
mais il est trop bas donc il n'est pas
assez dissuasif et là aussi ça rejoint
la réflexion que je fais de la finance
est un levier très puissant pour
réorienter les investissements et
améliorer la situation du climat dans
l'otan il parle du prix de la tonne de
co2 qui en effet s'est effondré après
des débuts prometteurs et donc il est
beaucoup trop bas pour inciter les
acteurs privés ou particuliers
entreprendre les indices nécessaires
pour réduire leurs émissions de gaz à
effet de serre augmenter l'efficience
énergétique donc faudrait un prix
mondial ou
plus élevées pour que ça fonctionne pas
d'accord au niveau européen sur les
suédois en revanche ils ont fait une
taxe les basses et ses 150 euros la
tonne de co2 alors c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être comme ça qu'il faut démarrer
pour pouvoir ensuite aller vers ce prix
mondial du carbone qui serait un niveau
suffisant la taxe sur les transactions
financières qui est revenue dans
l'actualité avec la tribune quatre
ministres prononçant pour le moment elle
est effective en france et en
grande-bretagne une chance qu'elle soit
étendue et quelle taxe sur les
transactions financières parce que
j'aime tellement la fête les 30 ans
elles existent tout jouer elle existe
mais qui sont des achats d'actions bon
eh oui mais c'est un problème parce que
du coup les capitaux s'échappe du bassin
de capitaux d'un nationale et je suis
pas sûr que ce soit une bonne chose pour
nos entreprises c'est pas ça augmente
leur coût du capital étant non non non
non c'est clair net on est parti tout
seul héros des temps restera tout seul
quelques quelques mecs qui sont prêts
c'est erwan en prenant un public alice à
prémunir fait qu'il voulait l'étendre
vous militez pour l'étendre mais c'est
c'est typiquement français à dire que
quel que soit le sujet notre réponse et
de la réglementation une taxe est là
aujourd'hui on a eu les deux cas il a
proposé d'étendre une taxe et puis ont
proposé de changer le
le code civil sur le l'objet des
entreprises oui pour un peu pour ajouter
maintenant que l'entreprise devait avoir
un but social le développement qui des
fleurs et tout aille bien
c'est c'est typiquement français ça ne
va rien changer en pratique ça va au
contraire avoir et sur les questions
fiscales et sur les questions
économiques des effets néfastes et des
effets non voulues ce qu'il faut c'est
plutôt ce que radio silva république il
faut que le secteur privé se saisisse du
sujet et pour ça il n'y a pas besoin de
créer des taxes mais la régulation ce
qui ce que disait marc landré de thaler
pourquoi les entreprises ont changé ce
soit la pression des opinions publiques
de leurs consommateurs c'est ça qui va
les faire bouger pas du tout la fin 2
c'est pas ce qui changera les mentalités
ça n'est pas une loi ninh ninh une
réglementation il a une attitude qui va
être intéressante à observer
d'ailleurs bruno lemerle évoqué ce matin
sur inter c'est l'attitude des fonds
souverains puisque évidemment ils sont
quand même en possession d'un levier
financier très important
d'ailleurs ils ont assis le paradoxe est
qu'ils ont passé une certaine façon leur
fortune sur les 10 heures les larmes on
va voir si aujourd'hui ils sont prêts à
investir de façon assez massive sur
d'autres énergies c'est un des enjeux
financiers importants mais c'est une des
questions qu'on se pose effectivement
c'est l'argent va là où le maximum de
profit généralement est ce qu'on peut
imaginer que l'ail et une partie finance
vertueuse et ce projet sont rentables
parce que si en effet le charbon on
arrête progressivement le charbon il
faut bien produire de l'électricité et
donc ses projets d'énergies
renouvelables peuvent trouver une
rentabilité et donc l'argent commence à
aller de plus en plus d'en verser projet
ce déficit d'offre qu'il faut combler
c'est aussi parce que les nouvelles
technologies permettent permettront
demain de stocker plus facilement
l'énergique encore été produites et donc
ça va baisser le coût de production est
donc le ramener à peu près au niveau de
celui de production peut être pas
forcément nucléaire mais en tout cas si
approché pour faire en sorte que le
retour sur investissement qui est
important à la base sur l'investissement
du moins ce sera beaucoup plus simple et
ça fait 1 simplifié à demain donc les
nouvelles technologies le temps qui
passe l'opinion publique est en même
temps le retour sur investissement qui
est quand même beaucoup plus rapide fait
que on va vers un développement de ces
énergies
verte et tant mieux avec un
renchérissement aussi de l'énergie
nucléaire dans le même temps parce qu'il
faut prévoir recyclage transnationales
aidera les grand carénage des centrales
sans pour autant les arrête alors c'est
une actualité qui est attendu demain
c'est celle du rapport sur notre dame
des landes l'aéroport je voudrais vous
poser une question à tous les capteurs
rapide
la réponse aussi s'il vous plaît vous
êtes pour ou contre l'aéroport de notre
dame des landes
je pense que la seule solution pour s'en
sortir c'est une troisième voie je pense
que le que l'affairé impasse est venue
symboliquement complètement ingérable si
c'est si on tranche d'un côté ou de
l'autre voilà c'est moi ce serait mon
sentiment est troisième avec moi je
pense qu'il est mort cet aéroport donc
on y prépare les esprits parce que après
peut-être que la solution est plus dans
le ferroviaire aussi pour ses unes
permettre aux habitants de durante ouest
de d'aller vers les grands hubs aériens
internationaux
c'est comme ça je pense qu'arsenal a dû
engager pâle figure
non non je pense qu'il faut le faire cet
aéroport parce qu'il ya des besoins et
aussi parce que toute façon si on le
fait pas la zad qui existe là se
déplacera ailleurs donc en vérité c'est
reculer pour mieux sauter parce que les
hadîths tirons sur un autre projet
d'infrastructures qu'ils contesteront
pour des questions écologiques
économiques ou parce qu'ils veulent
construire une société la société demain
donc ils rêvaient déjà dans les années
soixante dix avec la production de
chèvre ils iront ailleurs ça ira sur le
lyon-turin donc même si on annule non
mais par contre et puis surtout ce qui
est très intéressant c'est de se rend
compte de ce qui se passe dit datant de
la guerre là-bas dire qu'on peut parler
de guerre quel que soit le résultat
parce que si jamais le report n'est pas
construit et bien ils voudront
construire d'une société alternative
d'ailleurs ils ont changé le nom cpu z à
défendre co2 autonome a je crois à bâtir
ou un truc comme ça
enfin il ya yasam alors dans les deux
cas il faudra évacuer ça va parce qu'on
estime qu'il faut pour bien le faire il
faudrait près de la moitié des effectifs
de gendarmerie de france pour le faire
correctement
alors on a un troisième
pour une façon ça va pas se faire
maintenant il faut trancher là moi je
connais pas assez le sujet me prononcer
j'ai pas tout tout ce que je trouve mon
salut analyse sur cette question je
trouve déplorable que l'état recule
depuis autant de temps devant un
groupuscule de gauchistes qui occupe
l'est qui occupe le lieu c'est la preuve
d'un échec mais considérable de
l'autorité publique de l'autorité de
l'état dans ce pays et effectivement
c'est aussi un vrai sujet que ces
groupuscules se déplace de projet en
projet et empêchent aujourd'hui souvent
des infrastructures de se réaliser et
céline est un bon signe pour les
infrastructures ni pour la l'autorité de
l'état dans ce pays situé ajouté c'est
un petit clin d'oeil
y a pas que des gauchistes qui sont
contre le projet jusqu'à philippe de
villiers il ne veut pas du tout c'est
important ça rajouterait deux heures de
trajet pour leur campagne au puy du fou
alors que la lavande et les prêts loire
atlantique en fin de la 2 de l'aéroport
du sud qui est au sud de nantes pour
l'instant alors on aura sans doute pas
la réponse de maps demain c'est la
remise du rapport mené en janvier le
gouvernement donne son sa position sur
la question
on a pas mal de réactions alors
évidemment sur le sur le sommet climat
je viens au sujet principal avec le
droitier ce qui nous dit avec le chômage
qui ne cesse d'augmenter n'y était pas
plus urgent que ce sommet qui m'ont on
peut se poser la question jeu et l'a dit
ça on va parler aussi merci de me
rappeler marc ela dit qu'ils nous disent
cette rencontre n'a pas d'importance
avec l'absence des etats-unis c'est vrai
on en a parlé aussi mais bon est-ce que
c'est un acte fort ce n est guère ou
bill gates qui peuvent suppléer
l'absence du président oui parce qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup de collectivités
américaines qu'ils sont présentes dont
quito les fonds de pension dont on
parlait tout à l'heure qui prennent des
initiatives dans le sens du traité d'une
réduction des gaz à effet de serre bien
que les états unis n'est donc pas signer
cet accord il est toujours pas ratifié
on va passer à notre deuxième thème si
vous voulez bien avec un peu de
politique franco-française alors c'était
la contre-programmation de la soirée
télévisée hier pendant que tf1 sur tf1
laurent wauquiez afficher son objectif
de rassemblement 24
après devenu président des républicains
xavier bertrand a annoncé lui sur france
2 qu'il quittait son parti cette
défection va-t-elle affaiblir laurent
wauquiez va-t-elle donner des idées à
d'autres
ou n'est-ce qu'une clarification
salutaire l'aboutissement d'une aventure
individuelle dit certains ça du patron
des autres ans qui avait coupé les ponts
depuis longtemps on va regarder xavier
bertrand qui a donc c'est donc son
départ
et puis ce départ qui est commenté par
eric woerth député et l'air de l'oise et
qui est lui resté file républicain j'ai
décidé de quitter définitivement les
républicains j'ai voulu me taire pendant
cette campagne par respect pour les
adhérents par respect pour les candidats
mais là maintenant je n'ai pas envie de
me taire parce qu'il ya d'autres choses
aujourd'hui
avec elle je ne reconnais plus ma
famille politique labeyrie face à
l'europe
on a besoin de l'europe on doit être
exigeant vis-à-vis de l'europe et on en
a besoin
et puis j'aime plus cette politique de
l'agressivité et aussi des boucs
émissaires en réalité xavier bertrand il
a quitté les républicains depuis bien
plus longtemps
à quoi j'allais me participer de
l'élection présidentielle lui même avant
il a très peu participé à la primaire
très peu il n'a pas vraiment pris parti
entre les candidats il a voilà si son
choix je pense que son choix il est
essentiellement dictée par sa position
dans sa région d'ailleurs il le dit mon
parti c'est ma région
non c'est une excellente nouvelle
bon j'aime bien xavier bertrand bon et
puis sans doute un très bon président de
la région de la belle région hôte france
mais on avait besoin de cette
clarification idéologique républicain
donc dont je suis issue et on avait
besoin de moi j'avais dit d'ailleurs
pendant la campagne de deux filles ont
un moment où ça tanguait dans tous les
sens au moment du trocadéro comme que
c'était bien qu'il fallait un peu épuré
idéologiquement son temps c'est cette ce
rassemblement parce qu'il ya des gens
qui pensent tellement indifféremment les
uns des autres que à la fin si on veut
faire la synthèse c'est de l'eau tiède
et les gens n'y comprennent plus rien et
or les français en tout cas les
sympathisants de droite ils veulent des
mesures claires ils veulent qu'on contre
est le problème de l'insécurité culturel
de l'insécurité physique
le problème du chômage et là désolé mais
je ne vois pas en quoi c'est rechercher
des boucs émissaires comme dit
bertand je vois pas en quoi c'est une
dérive face contre l'europe que de dire
les choses simplement et de dire il faut
lutter contre le communautarisme
islamique par exemple rétablir la
sécurité dans les territoires perdus et
je pense que tant pis pour xavier
bertrand il y en aura peut-être d'autres
mais au moins là laurent wauquiez il
aura une unité une cohérence idéologique
et lui permettra de reconstruire les
républicains clarification je pense
aussi que laurent wauquiez a tout à
gagner à une clarification idéologique
je pense qu'effectivement s'il doit
avoir une chance de parvenir à ses fins
il faut qu'ils commencent par constituer
un socle clair c'est comme ça que ça
marche
enfin dans le système politique français
de toute façon il faut qu'il est un soc
leclerc et derrière dans un deuxième
temps mais c'est plus tard qu'il cherche
à l'élargir
mais d'abord il faut qu'il est un soc
leclerc donc de ce point de vue là
effectivement ça peut contribuer à
clarifier
après la question c'est y à t'il quand
même malgré tout pas un risque
hémorragique important parce que si le
si l'hémorragie devient trop forte si
effectivement après un xavier bertrand
un estrosi à juppé d'autres à une
question sur valérie pécresse même si
moi je doute fort que lé pécresse passe
à l'acte là dessus mais quand même il ya
un risque hémorragique donc si
l'hémorragie est trop forte
bon voila il lui malgré tout attention
ça peut fragiliser laurent wauquiez mais
mais sur la clarification je pense que
c'est oui paradoxalement peut-être aussi
je suis d'accord une bonne nouvelle pour
pour le nouveau patron de l air en tout
cas pour le moment nos internautes à la
question effectivement xavier bertrand
at il eu raison
ils sont 77% à répondre positivement
ewen le nom clarification salutaire des
et on met en même temps ça donne des
arguments à ceux qui disent laurent
wauquiez c'est une base très étroite à
droite mais de fait compte tenu du
contexte politique depuis mais la base
est l'air s'est réduite non quelques et
quelques
quel qu'ait été le candidat qui sait
laurent wauquiez mills avait été un
autre candidat de fait ça va s'arrêter
plus réduite qu'elle ne l'était il ya
saint et à quelques mois et à quelques
ya quelques années ça le départ de
xavier bertrand c'est probable foncia
des questions qui sont effectivement
personnel son électorat son assise
électorale et ce n'est pas du tout une
critique mais sont aussi électorale
n'est pas la même que ne correspond pas
à l'électorat et l'air de manière
parfaite c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
et il ya aussi font des questions
idéologiques comme on lisait je sais ce
que c'est une clarification je suis un
peu plus réservé parce que j'ai du mal à
voir aujourd'hui kane idéologique claire
des républicains
quelle est celle laurent wauquiez qui
et ali qui a des positions qui sont
effectivement très plutôt dur sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais qui en
même temps alliée avec des gens qui sont
très libéraux et est-ce que comment est
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir concilier sa et
xavier bertrand lui-même quitté l air
pas en disant qu' ils sont pas assez
libéraux mais plutôt qu'ils sont pas
assez sociaux alors que laurent wauquiez
venait lui-même là un mouvement se situe
me trompe pas s'appelle la droite
sociale donc clarification oui et en
même temps 24 ça fait un certain
épuration oubliés du parti ça fait un
certain tri mais je ne suis pas sûr que
la ligne politique soit beaucoup plus
clair aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était
alors c'est en tout cas les réactions
sont plutôt dans le sens d bertrand
n'avait plus grand-chose à faire chez
les républicains
sellal christophe qui nous dit son
avenir est sûre sa région lr peut très
bien s'en passer
james lui estime que xavier bertrand est
un profiteur et le droitiste il nous
revient en disant qu'il le veut rentrer
sa vie bertrand au gouvernement et qu'il
se rapproche du centre montois
c'est votre avis marc landré il veut
rentrer au gouvernement qui avait
d'antan non non je pense qu'il a il y là
il fait un calcul politique depuis son
élection 2015 à la tête de la région de
france avec les voix de la gauche
puisqu'il avait un candidat front
national face à lui moi je voulais
parler le soir du premier tour de l'art
des régionales il a pris un énorme coup
sur la tête
on est en 25 % des voix face à marine le
pen qui avait 44 il pensait pas faire
aussi peu et franchement il a une comme
révélation c'est un peu comme si la
vierge marie lui était apparue ce soir
là il s'est rendu compte que son avenir
son salut passerait par sa région et pas
par les partis politiques et encore
moins par paris il fait exactement les
mêmes calculs aujourd'hui au niveau de
la région que ce que laurent wauquiez a
fait il ya deux ans en se recentrant sur
sa région et en envoyant balader les
énarques les caciques paris enfant
jouant paris sur la province et xavier
bertrand fait le pari par rapport à 2022
parce que enfin faut pas se leurrer
c'est un secret de polichinelle depuis
deux ans xavier bertrand se prépare à la
présidentielle n'ont pas 2017 dont il
avait compris que il n'avait aucune
chance tant par la primaire qu'en dehors
de la primaire de la droite donc il
prépare 2022 il sait que son salut
passera par ses résultats au niveau de
la région de france et pas à travers des
combinés
donc deux parties au niveau de paris
vous parliez tout à l'heure de valérie
pécresse mais peut-être aussi christian
estrosi effectivement des barons locaux
comme ça on va les voir exister dans
leur région mais ils vont probablement
ici dans la région prend comme comme
séville et bertrand mais parce qu'en
réalité ce que vivent presque 1000
lr aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec une psi
instantanée saison 1 une tête nationale
qui fonctionnent assez mal et des élus
qui se rabat sur leurs collectivités
locales donc c'est comme ça qu'on a vu
que c'est ce qu'a fait ça a été la
stratégie de collomb à lyon et d'un
certain nombre d'autres grands élus
socialistes qui sont ici ou là au niveau
national c'est tellement n'importe quoi
restons sur le niveau au niveau local
c'est ce qui se dessine un peu la
question qui se pose sur le feu avec le
départ de xavier bertrand et peut-être
d'autres demain mais ça on ne sait pas
encore c'est qu'ils aient des droites
qui s'édifie qui sont différents tout le
monde l'admet c'est une nouvelle pour
personne c'est savoir si à quel point
elles sont irréconciliables comme disait
manuel valls pour la gauche parce que
s'il a le centre-droit et
irréconciliable avec la drau avec la
droite ça ni l'un ni l'autre n'a de
chances de l'emporter demain sauf à
s'allier avec avec d'autres partis ce
qui est pas dans leurs options
aujourd'hui on en vient d'orient rpr
mais l'inflation ça va durer un moment
en france lady déjà autour de cette
table plusieurs fois ça va forcément
durer un moment ça va pouvoir parce que
le l'espace de centre droit avec un
homme très occupé par emmanuel macron
donc il il plas une grande partie de cet
électorat là non sans raison parce qu'on
prend des mesures qui vont dans ce sens
là donc
donc ça va ça va de toute façon mettre
du temps parce qu'il va d'abord falloir
voir jusqu'à quel point la politique des
manuels macro ont réussi ou échoué
et puisque les minima qu'on occupe une
partie de cet espace et il va pas le
lâcher et qu' ils préparent déjà
évidemment son deuxième quinquennat
la solution elle est à droite c'est à
dire que c'est à dire que l'objectif de
laurent wauquiez et de siphonner front
national donc c'est 11 millions
d'électeurs qui sont portés sur marine
le pen il veut les faire revenir aux
républicains et là il adopte ici s'il
réussit il peut incarner une opposition
qui crédible et qui peut l'emporter en
2022 donc c'est ça le ski en train de se
passer est donc cette clarification
idéologique elle est hautement
souhaitable parce que jamais les
électeurs qui sont actuellement sur les
candidats du front national reviendront
tant qu'il aura pas eu ces
qualifications donc l explosion c'est
très bien mais en déplaisant
par des acteurs économiques en étant
justement sur un terrain très à droite
et alors que l'espace au centre et au
cnit ils sont fous laurent wauquiez je
veux dire c'est pas son lit faire calcul
mathématique assez simple il a vu que
françois fillon
avec toutes les casseroles qu'il a
traîné pendant la présidentielle a
réussi à faire 20% au premier tour de la
présidentielle donc il se dit moi en
faisant mieux et en n'ayant pas les
mêmes casseroles toi temps je suis
assuré de faire au minimum 20%
parce que c'est le socle idéologique de
la droite dure d'immanence il ya peu à
prendre cinq points au fn et vu l'état
de décomposition du fn et de marine le
pen c'est très compliqué de passer de 20
à 25
et je me qualifie pour le 2e tour donc
c'est ce calcul a qui dit qu'il veut
faire il veut faire il veut de faire des
quatre prochaines années le rendez-vous
du tête-à-tête avec le président de la
république et donc il se dit c'est moi
qui aujourd'hui veut incarner cette
force alternative par rapport au
président un public et je n'ai pas
besoin d'aller sur le centre il faut
effectivement que vous les échanges
allaient vers la droite
un mois maintenant j'aurai juste un mot
sur le laurent wauquiez les portraits
qui sont faits plus de ça il ya une
forme diabolisation peut-être un peu dur
mais c'est jamais ou rarement très
positives comme image c'est un
traitement qui lui est réservé non ça je
crois je crois pas l impression vague
souvenir que lorsque nicolas sarkozy a
émergé elle écrit les y ait peu de
portrait positif
souvenez vous la dernière campagne
françois fillon peu de force très
positif également après les les échos
qui reviennent et compris des gens de
son parti mais on sait que c'est pas la
consule générale non pas dans son parti
qu on a des amis sont sont très
critiques vis-à-vis de laurent wauquiez
moi je ne connais pas je sais pas si
c'est vrai je sais pas ce qu'il en est
mais effectivement il ay la ilaha illa
pas il n'a pas une image très positive
fera que les sondages le montrent et
comme le disait j'entendais un sondeur
récemment à dire qu'à très basse voilà à
dire poliment qu'il avait une marge de
progression très forte mais pour autant
je suis tout à fait d'accord à ce qui a
été dit sur la stratégie d'un exemple
voilà j'ai 20 % ou est ce que je
cherchais des points il me semble quand
même qu'il ya un manque dans cette dans
cette stratégie c'est que on ne gagne
pas des parts de marché sur le sujet
sans avoir une offre est aujourd'hui
l'offre elle est pas là est le problème
de la droite c'est de réconcilier c'est
de reconstituer cette offre quelques
mois poser et un style fallu qu'il soit
élu les humains n'ont en effet rien aux
français c'est vrai qu'on peut pas se
contenter de dire tout le temps la
droite est de retour à un moment il va
falloir donner ma vision est reconnu il
ya quelques est ce qu'on propose
mais donc tout cela renvoie à une
question et pour répondre aussi à la
vôtre c'est qui est laurent wauquiez en
fait c'est un peu ça aussi la question
que l'on se pose parce que la critique
qui lui est fait souvent c'est c'est un
aspect 0 est on va dire un coup je vais
d'autres où je vais dans l'autre j'ai
changé d'avis on a le droit de changer
d'avis avec les imbéciles ne changent
pas d'avis mais il ya une question sur
qui est il réellement sert au fond de
lui que pense-t-il d'un savant le sujet
là on n'a pas de certitudes au jour nous
parlons ça va peut-être venir mais on
appâte je pense que la critique elle est
plutôt de soleil nafilyan par exemple de
changer d'avis
et d'évoluer a été faite à jacques
chirac mais pas dans les mêmes termes
semble-t-il
prenez deux choses pour répondre à votre
question à tous les portraits de tous
temps de laurent wauquiez ont toujours
été négatif moi je me rappelle les
premiers portails sont établis quand il
était ministre il n'y avait pas un une
personne ne se déporterait je me
rappelle un portrait du point où il y
avait des choses gentilles qui est dit
sur cam était dit sur lui et je lui
avais dit à l'époque
faites attention monsieur le ministre
parce que dès maintenant si vous voulez
avoir un élan politique il va quand même
que vous mettiez des gens de votre côté
ce qui est que des gens qui crachent sur
vous et à votre âge c'est pas bon signe
deuxièmement rappelez-vous de chirac
dans les années 80 qu'est ce qu'on
disait de lui
facho chirac ça n'a pas empêché d'être
élu président la public et franchement
lui il en a tué il en a tué les
injustices dans un mois il a été lui n'a
pas été le cas avec la ligne repères et
élection qu'il est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus loin on ne va pas refaire
l'histoire
je rappelle la réponse vaut réponse à
notre question donc sur xavier bertrand
ait de raison de quitter les
républicains et bien vous êtes 70 % à
estimer que oui alors la france crée des
emplois
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle pour le
deuxième trimestre consécutif même si on
note un léger ralentissement ces trois
derniers mois
le pays attend quand même atteint quand
même un record avec 25 millions
d'emplois salariés et la structure de
ses emplois salariés elles restent quand
même fragile avec beaucoup d'intérêt mme
beaucoup de temps partiel et beaucoup de
postes dans les services alors charles
beigbeder faut-il voir le verre à moitié
plein ou à moitié vide
non mais moi j'ai plein toujours
mentionné brodeur droit mais c'est bien
c'est bien mais il faut aller plus loin
dans les réformes
là ce qu'a fait le gouvernement des
leurs philippe sous l'égide emmanuel
macron ces sélections d'ailleurs c'est
la question sur le territoire philippe
où c'est le fruit du gouvernement
précédent
là elle a eu un petit choc de confiance
liée aux réformes courageuses et les
ordonnances mac rançon
le travail ce qui est des reald
rigidifie marché du travail qui était un
des grands problèmes français le
problème c'est que il faut et puis une
image améliorée de la france à
l'international cette année avec des
investissements guerre bat syrienne
swiss ici parce que vous savez ici parce
que maintenant les entrepreneurs ils
sont toujours très bien
j'ai déjà bien sûr je vais embaucher
plutôt que je vais débaucher donc s'il
ya eu un début de signes encourageants
mais le problème c'est les prélèvements
obligatoires donc c'est sûr dépense
publique c'est sûr prélèvements
obligatoires qui dont on crève
on a dépassé danemark là ça y est on est
à 47 8 %
on est encore maintes d'europe voire
quasiment du monde développé en termes
de prélèvements obligatoires est là il
n'y a pas grand chose parce que emmanuel
macron basse et 1300 fonctionnaires de
moins sûr sur 2018 cc c'est ridicule
donc alors on en a on est à six millions
et demi d'agents la fonction publique et
est donc clairement ce qui est des
gaspillages il faut il faut tailler
faire des économies est ce que ce qui
permettra de baisser les prélèvements
obligatoires et puis je reprends une
formule de nathalie kosciusko morizet
qu'il disait il faut que les dépenses
prennent l'escalier et que les impôts
prennent l'ascenseur vers le bas parce
que sa relance aussi l'économie et ça
crée des richesses et ça ça fait baisser
le chômage plus rapidement qui ensuite
génère des recettes fiscales qui
permettent de réduire les déficits
le problème c'est que mutti merkel a
complètement anesthésié macron dès son
élection à lisant surtout pas question
que tu fasse quoi que ce soit ça les
prélèvements obligatoires tu dois te
dire tu es 3% et du coup on est bloqué
et ça ce qui arrange bien d'ailleurs les
entreprises allemandes parce que si les
entreprises françaises retrouver des
marges de manoeuvre
ben elle serait peut-être pas en si
bonne position pour les grands marchés
internationaux donc n'oublions pas cet
aspect aussi après sa brillante
démonstration nouvelle bonne nouvelle
est bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle pour
une fois pas sans la passion de
recueillir
franchement on est au delà des chiffres
il ya un chiffre qu'il faut retenir un
seul en tendance annuelle ou créer 260
mille emplois par an là
ces chiffres là c'est un niveau qu'on
n'a pas connue depuis le début des
années 2000 et c'est pas grâce à
emmanuel macron en tout cas pas encore
peut-être que si ça continue les
règlements sur les rails là pour le coup
je dis rendons à césar ce qui est du cph
françois hollande c'est le cce s'est pas
de responsabilité merci mais si c'est la
baisse du coût du travail qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui les gens il ya dix
recrutement s'est pas encore pas encore
donc ok emmanuelle bescheron les
salaires difficile de savoir alors à
rendre à césar rincon
non mais je suis d'accord marc landré
oui mais enfin c'est juste d'ailleurs
c'est même pas un commentaire politique
c'est juste c'est l'effet le chiffre oui
chronologique le dernier trimestre qui
d'ailleurs est moins bon que le
précédent mais le bilan annuel puisque
c'est effectivement intéressant dessous
je regardais le trend guara muriel
pénicaud d'avoir décidé d'arrêter de
regarder les chiffres mensuels du
chômage commencent n'a aucun intérêt
alors regardons les sur le trent je suis
d'accord et sur le traîne donc ça
remonte forcément à l'année précédente
donc on peut pas porter crédit emmanuel
macron et aujourd'hui l'on travaille sur
ce sujet là ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'il ne va pas y avoir d'impact des
ordonnances travaillons valoir lors des
prochains mois on pourra on pourra juger
à ce moment là bon après le
il s'agit pas uniquement de créer il
s'agit de probablement aussi soin de
créer davantage soin d'eux - détruire
parce que le problème du chômage c'est
la balance entre concret ce qu'on
détruit et là on voit bien qu'on a
encore un sujet donc il faut soit
détruire - soit créer davantage et
deuxième point le paysage est quand même
assez contrasté 1
d'ailleurs vous visiez au départ s'il ya
des secteurs où sa porte
exemple intérim cdd intérim terme qui
augmente cela il ya aussi des régions sa
porte mieux que d'autres enfin c'est le
paysage est assez compliqué je crois que
la lhouest c'est mieux qu'à l'est enfin
bon voilà il faut regarder
les choses de façon un peu détaillé pour
bien comprendre ce qui se passe je vous
donne la parole dans une seconde d'avoir
le nom juste peau avant vous dire que
vous êtes 64% pour le moment à ne pas
être rassurés par ces porteurs bons
chiffres sur la création d'emplois donc
vous êtes moins optimiste internautes
que nous ne le sommes tout quelques nous
inviter leçon au tour de ceux de cette
table jean-marc pour le souligner marc
landré et erwan maintenant pardon je
vous avais dit que vous donnez la parole
donc elle est à bout non merci
non mais faut chasser la correcte les
internautes se faire pour concilier
notre nos commentaires est-ce que ce que
et leurs votes c'est que il faut se
féliciter et il faut que tout le monde
autour de la table a fait de ses très
bons de ces bons résultats font sait
également que c'est plus le fait des
politiques menées par manuel valls
d'ailleurs plus que françois hollande à
la fin du quinquennat de françois
hollande par une tendance aussi
rpm qui n'est pas acquis n'est pas le
seul fait de la hausse
il faut être assuré toutefois est-ce
qu'on peut être assurée aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que cette tendance positive
des derniers mois annoncent des
lendemains qui chantent est évidemment
non comme ce qu'on est encore loin des
réformes structurelles comme le disait
monsieur beigbeder de tala on n'y est
pas on n'y est pas on n'y est pas du
tout les réformes la fin du match le
travail d'ailleurs le gouvernement l'a
dit il devra être prolongée et il n'ya
rien n'a été fait sur les dépenses
publiques
ce sont des vrais ce sont là est le
coeur le coeur de la réforme il est là
parce que tant que le système étatique
et administratif français fonctionnera
comme il fonctionne on n'aura jamais une
croissance forte et d'ailleurs ils nous
sont closes et la commission européenne
vient de publier un des résultats et des
statistiques montrant que la france
était bien avait un point un tiers de
croissance de moins que les que laisser
les pays homologues sur les cinq à dix
dernières années donc on a on a des on a
des ddd des chaînes aux pieds et qu'il
faut qu'il faut lever progressivement et
aujourd'hui on est en train de les lever
mais on en est encore loin mais ce qui
est dommage c'est quand on ne donne pas
notre plein potentiel
on pourrait être à 3% de croissance
peut-être même plus si on avait les
prélèvements obligatoires normaux dans
la moyenne européenne et que on est
prisonnier de dépasser sur des pensées
de ses surprises et on attend aussi
attaque pas et c'est un gros problème
a contrario malgré ces prélèvements
obligatoires je vous la corde trop élevé
mais qui finance quand même un centre de
service public que non pas à due
concurrence des pays étrangers il ya
quand même un propose yves dont on doit
satisfaire prenez l'industrie
l'industrie c'est la première fois en
2016 qu'on a créé plus usine quand on a
détruit en france première fois depuis
le début de l'année 2006 plutôt un
premier temps à 100 et à sang du bébé on
a eu un effondrement et deuxièmement
deuxièmement on parle de l'intérim ont
dit que c'est
on dit que ces pré carré d'art à messi
vont réintégrer les emplois intérimaires
dans les secteurs qui les emploient
l'industrie pour la première fois depuis
les années 2000 à ont recréé de l'emploi
en intégrant un point termeer fin 2016
donc on voit qu'on a une tendance à
l'amélioration c'est pas suffisant
je vous l'accordé mais le trend est
positif et il faut continuer en ce sens
la traîne de positif vous parliez du
croissant d'or je ne pense pas que
béziers en fasse partie a priori
porte le mieux économiquement en tout
cas c'est là que robert ménard a fait
une nouvelle fois parler de lui sur la
fiche censé faire campagne pour
l'arrivée du tgv dans sa ville on voit
une femme ligotée sur dérailler un train
à vapeur qui s'approche avec ce slogan
avec le tgv elle aurait moins souffert
campagne ignoble dénonce les un humour
et référence au western réplique le
maire de béziers qui avaient été élus en
2014 avec le soutien du front national
la justice a été saisie et cette
campagne n'est pas du goût de marlène
schiappa la secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
marlène schiappa qui était l'invité du
talk du figaro est interrogé par i frère
ce matin on écoute moi je trouve que
c'est un deal à on n'est pas dans de la
création robert ménard c'est un élu de
la république ça lui donne des
obligations alors qu'on combat les
violences envers les femmes on ne peut
pas comme ça faire la promotion dira
voilà une méthode pour tuer quelqu'un
plus vite alors qu'il ya des femmes qui
ont déjà été tués de cette manière ces
dernières années alors moi j'ai réagi en
interpellant le préfet puisque c'est le
rôle du prêt notamment de maintenir
l'ordre et veiller aux troubles à
l'ordre public le préfet pardon a décidé
d'en faire appel au procureur de le
saisir le procureur a décidé d'ordonner
une enquête mais c'est je crois revers
mais wigan et sa défense tout petit peu
j'en ai marre qu on s'offusque que pour
un oui pour un non on s'indigne on se
drape dans sa toge tels jean moulin il
ya un moment
ok il a fait une connerie c'est une
erreur il savait pas qu'il y en a plus
il y avait eu un fait divers sordide où
une femme avait été écrasé par un train
ligotée sur les origines donc il
s'excuse et et puis mais maintenant font
franchement il faut pas non plus donner
une dimension gigantesque un petit truc
de potash je sens que j'en info va vous
dire que c'est un récidiviste en la
matière
robert ménard sur les affiches un peu
provocant admettons qu'il n'était pas au
courant du fait divers c'est très
possible c'est possible admettons n'ya
pas n'y a pas de souci avec ça en
revanche soyons pas naïfs sur le fait
qu'il cherche à faire parler de lui
voilà d'ailleurs il a réussi voyez
qu'est ce qu'on fait là
ces séries d'haddad affiche vise à ce
que ça quand même à faire affaire à
faire causer en provoquant c'est
toujours la même technique je veux dire
et puis on tombe à pieds joints dedans
on en parle c'est comme la fois il
n'avait pas fait exprès rajouter sur une
photo une pancarte béziers sur des
trains de migrants se disant sois disant
que tous les migrants arrivent en france
voulait aller à béziers il n'est pas
fait exprès par hasard l'ordinateur
avait créé une pancarte béziers sur le
train il a pas de bol vous avancez un
peu trop sur le terrain de votre album
est le tg il faut qu'on fasse quand il
ya trop de tgv maintenant le risque l'or
pur plaisir oui non mais moi je connais
pas la nel je connais pas le dossier
donc je peux pas vous dire s'il a une
nécessité que le tgv s'arrête à béziers
jeu je redis en revanche la campagne
affiches ya pas que celle là il y en a
quatre ou cinq bons elles sont
délibérément provocatrice elle vise à
faire parler d'eux à faire parler de lui
alors nos internautes il a également
sont nombreux à répondre et à nous dire
pour le moment à 60% que cette affiche
doit être interdite
jean baptiste ces merdes y en
merci d'avoir rejoint mais cette
implosion vous allez mourir tout le bien
ou le mal
on pense sur internet ces campagnes
je vais reprendre les mots de léon
zitrone qui disait qu'on parle de moi en
bien où on parle de moi en mal peu
importe l'essentiel sans qu'on parle de
moi c'était quand même des bons moments
qu'ils voteraient bien au phénomène de
buzz en général cercle vertueux l'avant
l'avalanche informationnel on se
critique on se crie ça se cristallisent
mais on en parle on en parle on en parle
aujourd'hui effectivement on en parle
donc ça fonctionne pour le maître en la
matière c'est quand même donald trump
qui fait des buts incroyables contre
hillary clinton au temps durant la
campagne que même récemment et hillary
clinton qui répondait donc c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est qu'une
cristallisation avec un clan du pour et
du contre et donc les gens en parlent ça
fonctionne et effectivement il ya une
sorte de buzz
donc c'était hier à 9h14 robert ménard a
tweeté sa nouvelle affiche une heure
plus tard il y avait déjà des montages
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir les voir les
montages assez rigolo parce que c'était
le visage de robert ménard à la place du
visage de la femme qui allait se faire
écraser par cet horrible tgv une heure
plus tard encore l'ancien ministre
laurence rossignol voit dans cette
affiche un parallèle avec le fameux
faits divers dont vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure
elle s'énerve elle s'offusque une heure
plus tard encore la secrétaire d'état à
l'égalité femmes/hommes marlène schiappa
critique une campagne pour elle c'est
odieux et annonce qu'elle va saisir le
préfet une heure plus tard encore en
continu c'est vraiment un déroulé
robert ménard bondi à oui tiens je
m'étonne la réactivité il trouve bizarre
les réactions outrées et paranoïaque
c'est ainsi qu'il réagit et il rappelle
qu'il a fait référence à un western bon
lui référence au restaurant sont
possibles et les internautes sur tous
les internautes
surtout ils savent qu'il faut que connu
mais mais mais pour moi c'est une fausse
innocence parce qu'il faut bien savoir
il faut retourner sur le compte twitter
de robert ménard et si vous regardez son
compte twitter effectivement il a tweeté
toutes les affiches mais il a fait un
tweet unique pour cette affiche là parce
que on a quand même de grandes chances
qu'ils pensaient que les choses allaient
s'offusquer et que la plupart des
personnes allaient réagir de manière
assez violente et ils sont nombreux à le
critiquer quelques-uns y voit même un
plan de com et que ça on dit même si ça
se trouve même si s'être même si on ne
trouve pas ça drôle
on peut dire que la campagne depuis des
réussites et on parle de ménard il a
réussi son coup hameedi avait marlène
schiappa qui était au talk on l'a
interrogé sur ce sujet je vais demander
ce n'était pas aussi un piège
s'il n'était pas tombé dans le piège
christine vous remercie d'avoir saisi le
préfet de l'hérault contre la campagne
de publicité à béziers mais céline à
regrette que vous tombiez un peu dans le
piège du buzz de robert ménard
vous êtes tombé dedans c'est lui faire
de la publicité n'écoutez c'est une
vraie question je me suis posé la
question bien évidemment mauvaise pub
c'est toujours de la pub effectivement
du coup on parle de robert ménard mais
j'ai choisi de ne pas entrer dans les
considérations de savoir ce que
souhaitait ou pas robert ménard et de
condamner très fermement cela ils
compris en faisant appel effectivement
au préfet qui lui même a saisi le
procureur et voilà est donc tombé dans
le piège et nous aussi on en parle donc
l'essentiel c'est qu'on parle de lui
c'est qu'on parle de robert ménard
il a gagné il ya une sensibilité au delà
de la polémique sur faute il en parle ou
pas il ya une sensibilité exacerbée sur
ces questions c'est vrai qu'une affiche
qui peut faire penser à ce que les
femmes soit dévalorisé au dégradé
n'aurait sans doute pas autant fait
parler dans un contexte autre que très
probablement
c'est certain le contexte est très
aujourd'hui très très sensible sur ce
sujet des violences faites aux femmes
bon après moi je veux dire que je viens
de la voir encore j'ai vu ce matin sa
fille je la comprends toujours pas je
vois pas en quoi c'est censé aider le
le tgv à venir et
je sais pas comment est ce qu'on peut
arriver à une idée pareille pour vendre
le tgv honnêtement c'est quand même
assez c c'est un créatif sans doute
toute cette raison que je sois qui la
paille et j'aime ça mais moi je trouve
que tout ce qui s'ensuit d'un pathétique
à ce que la ministre les tous ses
parlementaires n'ont que ça à faire de
commenter cette affiche
honnêtement de mauvais goût est
complètement idiote
est ce que la loi nous voir le reste on
doit voir faire intervenir le préfet 1
c'était clair sur la façon dont certains
font de la politique
oui bien sûr mais jamais on l'a mais
voilà est-ce que l'on doit elle
interdire pour autant pour moi je pense
qu'il fallait pas aidé enfin il faut
très il faut voter sanaa d'un revers de
la main et s'il est ce qu'ils jugeront
sont les électeurs de robert ménard en
souhaitant qu'ils le sortent pour toutes
ses bêtises va être fait le parallèle
peut parler vous je suis d'accord et
vous dire aujourd'hui il ya des sujets
auxquels on peut plus parler dans son
but par les affiches qu'on peut plus
montrer je veux dire bigard il au
chômage
jean marie bigard géré avec ses blagues
graveleuses sur les femmes c'est fini
lui des rideaux chômage et des retraites
c'est fini
prenez une tech ce mois ci permet de
l'animateur de france 2 je suis pas fan
de texte qui présente les amours il a
été mise à pied
parce qu'il a fait une mauvaise blague
sur une femme avec des yeux au beurre
noir bah franchement s'ils ont pu parler
de rien maintenant c'était je me tais et
bien c'est le mot de la fin par claude
rey et ça tombe bien vous tézier parce
qu'en plus du temps pour parler mais ne
quittez pas figaro life figaro live ou
marie laëtitia reçoit pour conversation
jean jouzel le climatologue vice
président du giec et j'imagine que c'est
pour parler du climat
merci et à demain pour un nouveau point
de vue présentée par guillaume roquette
[Musique]